the North Carolina ninth district new
election is getting very very
interesting I'll quickly catch you up if
you haven't been following this so in
November of 2018 one of the 435
districts that was up for re-election
was North Carolina's ninth district and
that was ultimately a face-off between
Republican Mark Harris and Democrat Dan
McReady Mark Harris the Republican
supposedly won by 905 votes very very
close race but then we very quickly
found out about massive massive election
fraud once again I know I'm a broken
record on this in person voter fraud not
a problem even though Republicans claim
it is election fraud including voter
suppression but also what took place in
North Carolina's ninth district that's
the actual problem and what happened in
that ninth district race is that a
well-known Republican operative whose
name escapes me McCray doubtless jr. I
think it is F McCray and MacRay Dallas
jr. anyway
Dallas jr. coordinated basically two
sets of actions to influence the results
one was sending Republican operatives to
the homes of Democratic voters or
particularly overwhelmingly Democratic
voters and Democratic areas collecting
absentee ballots saying I'm a poll
worker I'm going to get this delivered
for you and just destroying them okay so
the some ballots assumed to be
Democratic ballots for Dan McReady were
simply never delivered the other side of
this scam was showing up in collecting
uncompleted absentee ballots and filling
them in for the Republican Mark Harris
absolute horrible horrible crimes
disenfranchisement an attack on the
basic democratic institutions of our
country people should go to prison I
don't know if they will but it was bad
enough that a new election was ordered I
told you when I first reported this I
don't know if Mark Harris is going to
run this is not just an automatic redo
of the November election with the same
candidates this is a special election
and Mark Harris my true
to run he might choose not to run and
indeed
Mark Harris has announced he's not even
going to be running in the redo or not
redo the new election in North
Carolina's ninth district he says that
the reason is poor health that may be
true it may be that he realizes that
this is completely shameful and he
doesn't want to show his face it may be
that he's been advised that he's simply
not going to win and it would be very
embarrassing for that to happen so he's
not running but you know what he is
doing endorsing the Union County
Commissioner named Stoney rushing who is
a big Confederate booster a lover of the
slave-owning south of the Civil War so
the good news is this guy rushing is
basically unknown and should lose and it
should add yet another seat for
Democrats in the House and what was a
big big takeover of the House of
Representatives for Democrats in the
midterms that's the good news this
Russian guy probably is not going to win
the only small thing that this Russian
guy is known for is fighting for
Confederate symbols quite a guy right
the the back story on this is that some
Confederate flags appeared on an old
County Courthouse in North Carolina and
later those Confederate flags were
removed this county commissioner Stoney
Rushing's said the Confederate flag
should be flown at the courthouse he
obviously owns a firing range here's a
picture with a gun supporting the Second
Amendment like a boss as his ad says his
firing range has a newsletter and a few
years ago the newsletter joked about the
death of a black man in Florida named
Rudy Eugene you might remember this is
the infamous bath salts case Rudy Eugene
was killed by a police officer while he
was high on bath salts and he has also
put out photoshopped images of Barack
Obama and Al Sharpton he's a real piece
of work and exactly what we would expect
the straight-up caricature of the racist
ignorant Republicans who miss the days
before the Civil War
but he actually has a chance of winning
the upside here Pat is it's unlikely he
would win the downside is that special
elections often have very low turnout if
people don't even understand what's
going on or when it's happening or why
it's taking place this is a guy who
could actually end up winning it's
unlikely but everybody has to vote and
special election turnout is always a
real concern yeah I'm hoping that Stoney
rushing comes in second place as did the
Confederates in the Civil War but you
never know people do have to go out and
vote and I am kind of worried that
people in North Carolina in this
district will view him as so crazy that
it's not even necessary to go out and
support the Democrat like the Democrats
gonna be a shoo-in
you never know especially with special
elections as you point out yep so
everybody's got a vote and then by the
way notice that completely gone or never
even really present in the discussions
about this is the idea of Mark Harris or
the Republican operative being charged
criminally
criminally it's going to be difficult
with Mark Harris he's claiming he didn't
know anything about what these
Republican operatives were doing maybe
hard to prove that he did and maybe he
actually didn't but at least the
Republican operatives who did this
election fraud should be charged
criminally and should if found guilty
have to be punished by the full extent
to the fullest extent of the law
how much did any of them know as they
were doing it we don't exactly know but
someone needs to be punished for this
the same way that when Republicans try
to prove how easy it is to do in-person
voter fraud and they get caught and the
book is thrown at them rightly so the
people that committed this attack on the
democratic systems and participated in
this disenfranchisement they need to be
held accountable and hopefully at least
the Republican operative who spearheaded
this is going to face charges I'm not
holding my breath and the most likely
scenario is Mark Harris isn't running
he's not going to be seated in the House
of Representatives
everybody's gonna hope that this is just
all completely forgotten and that
actually is arguably the biggest
miscarriage of justice here people need
to face the consequences for what
they've done